francine artistes tourangelle est venu à
l'achat teulière pour partager sa
passion de la peinture dans un jardin à
histoires gaz ou n'est plus mais
pourtant il est partout quand on est
saisi laurentienne l'appel gaz ou qu'est
ce qu'il avait de particulier et thé
janvier golo tout ce qui était jardin
plant in arms était partout on n'avait
pas le droit de marcher là parce qu'il y
avait une telle plante gaz ou avait
laissé la peinture pour créer un hectare
de bonheur son jardin et le bonheur se
transmet depuis deux générations en
générations nous l'envient c'est déjà de
continuer à faire vivre son jardin ce
qu'ils étaient un petit peu puis le
faire évoluer
continuez nous en tant qu'artiste à se
rencontrer et ouvrir une possibilité de
faire le dialogue entre l'art et le
jardin le bonheur c'est d'être dans ce
jardin qui a vraiment une âme avec ce
magnifique freine du maroc qui avait
vraiment mais voilà moi c'est mon lieu
d'enfance où j'ai toute une histoire
familiale je suis ravie de mes enfants
là vivent aussi des fleurs de vergers
honte ont poussé au verger on peut lire
les livres fleurs de rebecca loulou ou
croisés gilles cadets d'habitude elle
donne des couleurs et des fleurs aux
murs de la ville aujourd'hui son art de
la rue s'est mise au vert une douzaine
d'artistes souvent amis de gaz ou sont
là faut regarder lui son sourire ils
sont tous heureux d'être là nous aussi
fascinant l'endroit
magique c'était agréable sévère c'est
luxuriant mai mais alors vraiment
plaisir à venir te laisse prendre les
pinceaux et les palettes je vais
interpeller les gens des visiteurs qui
vont venir je vais leur demander de me
dessiner les eaux peindre les la
personne qu'il aura le plus apporté de
savoirs et de connaissances dans leur
famille rebecca loulou a décidé de
peindre une de ces grands mères celle
qui lui a transmis l'amour de la
peinture et de l'art soleil plus art +
jardin ce week end l'hectare de bonheur
de gaz ou a tenu sa promesse